[Music]  members continue their discussion with  EU leaders with dutch Prime Minister  Mark Rutte er he is the seventh EU  leader to come to Parliament to debate  the future of Europe members debate the  EU s response to US President Donald  Trump's decision to back out of the Iran  nuclear deal and the impact this could  have on Europe drones are increasingly  appearing in Europe skies Parliament is  updating civil aviation rules and  introducing the e use first safety  guidelines for light unmanned aircraft  around a quarter of Road Transport  emissions comes from heavy-duty vehicles  the Parliament calls for co2 emissions  from trucks buses and coaches to be  better monitored members are in favor of  granting exceptional emergency financial  assistance to Ukraine this 1 billion  euros in aid should boost economic  stabilization and encourage reforms